I want to start this next segment with a reminder
or sort of a notice, I guess.
And I don't know that people are necessarily
thinking in these terms.
The election is about to get going.
Voting starts in six weeks.
The first absentee ballots are going to be
going out in North Carolina on September 4th.
In Pennsylvania, they go out on September
14th.
In Michigan.
They go out on September 19th.
And this is incredibly important for a few
reasons.
Number one, Trump doesn't really have three
and a half months to to fix something or to
have some big win to get voters back.
For many voters, he has six weeks.
And when you look at those three states that
will most soon be voting.
Biden is up ahead, is up by two in North Carolina,
up by seven in Pennsylvania and up by seven
in Michigan.
Those are averages of recent pollings, according
to Real Clear Politics.
This means that the election is essentially
now Trump has six weeks to turn around the
polls in those states because as people start
voting in September and October, that leaves
fewer people whose minds can be changed in
the second half of October.
And in the last days before the election.
So the closing arguments of the campaign,
as it were.
Need to start happening very, very soon.
In 2016, 47 million people voted before Election
Day, either within person early voting or
vote by mail absentee.
The assumption this year because of Corona
virus is that there will be dramatically more
than 47 million people voting either early
or by mail, especially by mail.
I sent in my absentee ballot request form
yesterday.
So this means a few different things.
Number one, the vigilance about voter suppression
has to be escalated dramatically now.
I've made an effort since last election not
to do the thing where I start talking about
voter suppression.
October 5th, right of the year of the election.
We've been talking about voter suppression
for years at this point.
We've been covering the voter purges.
We've been covering the opposition to vote
by mail.
We've been talking about voting machines and
all of it.
So it should already be up.
But we need to even talk more about that.
And I'm going to talk more about that on Friday.
We would expect that the president will become
even more erratic sooner than later.
But really, we now need to realize what it
is that we're doing here.
You know, people talk about the most important
election of my life.
I believe this is the most important election
I will be voting in.
So, you know, we talked a little bit about
this on the bonus show before.
Think about the 2012 election.
Barack Obama had been president for four years.
Significant recovery from the Great Recession
of 2008.
Economic expectations were positive.
And you can find clips of me saying in October
of 2012, I'm voting for Obama over Mitt Romney.
But the reality is that if Romney wins, we're
probably going to have a good economy for
the for the next four years.
All indicators were that the traditional economic
signals were pretty solid, that the economic
policy of Mitt Romney would certainly tweak
the trajectory a little bit.
But Romney had a different tax policy idea.
Romney had a different health policy idea.
But generally speaking, whoever won in 2012
was going to preside over for relatively good
years in the economy by all of the standard
measures.
This is a very different situation than what
we have today.
And so it wasn't that the 2012 election wasn't
important.
But even at the time, not just in retrospect,
I remember having the recognition and it's
on record and video clips.
You can go, in fact, check me that this was
not the most important election I was participating
in.
We now we're in a situation where we will
either have four years of damage done by a
reactionary, ignorant buffoon or we are going
to have eight years of an even more compromised,
more unhinged Trump in the ladder, four of
those eight years.
We are sort of on the precipice of either
diving even deeper into the deep end of ignorance
and narcissism, or we can start to get the
house in order.
We can start to regain respect from our traditional
allies.
We can start to get away from being the laughing
stock that we have become.
We can resume dealing with the climate crisis.
We've gone the opposite direction on climate.
And fortunately, Joe Biden has adopted elements
from the Green New Deal and from Bernie Sanders
climate platform.
So is it perfect?
No, but we know, you know, this analogy or
this this example of if a boat leaves.
New York across the Atlantic Ocean.
What after 10 miles is only a difference of
a few hundred yards in terms of the angle
can end up with you in Europe or Africa as
you cross the Atlantic Ocean.
So that's the importance of starting to right
the ship today.
We hopefully would be seeing an increase rather
than a decrease in the number of people with
health insurance.
If Joe Biden were to win in November, we could
stop worrying that if a Supreme Court justice
were to get sick or die or retire, it would
plague us with decades more of the conservative
nonsense that we've been seeing.
So these are not trivial matters.
And I know it feels like a way off.
November is more than three months for some
voters.
It starts in six weeks.
For many voters, the decision about who they're
going to vote for is going to be made in the
next four to five weeks and they will vote
in six weeks.
So time is flying right now for a lot of us.
The days look quite similar.
Those of us who are still socially distancing
for months in quarantine each day felt long,
but the four months have just flown by.
Six weeks are going to fly by.
The next three months are going to fly by.
And if I don't feel that I've done everything
I can to stop this insanity, I would not be
able to live with myself.
So it is now election time.
We've got the conventions coming up in whatever
form they take place.
We have potentially debates coming up and
voting starts in six weeks.
The opportunity will be there for October
surprises and then that's it.
I mean, this thing is almost over.
Are we going to have four more years of utter
depravity or can we remove this lunacy from
the Oval Office and start to.
It's just the start.
It's just turning the ship.
Can we start to reintroduce sanity to our
federal leadership?
And of course, one of the biggest issues to
consider is coronavirus.
And that's what I want to talk about a little
bit.
Next,